In your opinion,
what are some of the best soft skills to have at a large tech company and why?
That is a good question. Um,
what's popping guys.
Hey, all right. Today I am very, very excited for this video.
Why is because we finally got sponsored?
So this video is gonna be sponsored by blue apron,
as you can see the delicious food as laid out. All right.
So blue apron is a meal kit service,
and I'm so excited because finally I can make healthy food for myself because
you know me, I always go out and eat pokey bowls. Or when I cook,
it looks like this.
Huh?
Oh my God. That's pretty disgusting. But yeah,
so I'm very excited and I get to eat all this free food.
And another reason why I'm super happy about this is that, you know,
they make really delicious and healthy food. And since you know,
I'm getting jacked,
this is perfect for me and an something for you guys.
The first 50 people to sign up will get $50 off your first two
weeks of blue apron, which is great.
It makes it pretty much like as cheap as buying groceries. Okay. All right.
Can you, can you come in and we have a special guest today.
We got the girl at three Oh four.
Her name.
Is Ariel. Can you tell me a little bit about yourself?
I'm a software engineer. I just graduated college 2017.
Oh, I do iOS, but I did web before that. So iOS is totally new to me,
but I guess doing my job.
Nice. We actually have another special guest later on,
but you'll have to keep watching to find out who, all right,
what food do you want to make? We have three different steak meals.
We got, we got wild, Alaskan fit to Cine.
Pasta. We got lemon grass, ginger Turkey burgers.
And finally we have Parisian steaks.
Oh my God. Oh, wow. I want steak free.
So it's all laid out. You know, one to six,
I asked you guys on Twitter to give us, you know,
your best questions about software engineering.
So we're going to be answering this while we cook.
Oh, those are French fries are dumb. Yeah. Those are French fries.
Okay.
Oh my God.
French reduction. This is my UCO also.
[Inaudible].
Oh, so yeah. So which one do you want?
Choose you either can choose the lemon grass, Turkey or the fettuccine.
I'm going to read it. It's better to Cheney. Fascinating. All right, go ahead.
Wait, do I get it now? Yeah. It's so simple. It's time. Okay.
Instructions are so simple. Like a competition or anything.
Just pop it up. Well, I use the oven for them. If you're not cooking,
I'm cooking. I'm cooking. It's part of my video. Yeah.
You know, once I get my new apartment,
because my new apartment has a dope kitchen and a dope business, right? Yeah.
It's actually, really? Yeah. If you watch my videos, you would know.
Whatever. No one watches your videos. That's not true. Wow.
It's like in Japanese and stuff. It's from new parents, all this.
Oh my gosh. Manny's comes in a little thing like this. Wow.
You never need to buy any.
I don't think I've ever gotten believed from before.
So this is like a new experience.
First question by Rosa Noor. Hello. Joma OPA.
I do curious what makes you move from software engineer to data scientist?
Thank you. Yeah, that's a great question. I actually got asked that many,
many times.
So the main reason why I switch is that I want to do something new because the
first time I switched was during my internship.
So I did software engineering internship at LinkedIn,
and then I want to try data science. And I did that at Facebook.
And then after I did at Facebook, I realized that, you know,
maybe sometimes it's not like I really like the product more than actually
solving the architecture problems and stuff like that.
So that's why I really like data science because you're a lot closer to the
product because they say you're analyzing data to try to find product
recommendations.
So it's closer to a PM role than what software engineer would be.
And I realized that that's one thing I really care about because I was really
into startups,
really into making my own products and data science is closer to product
management than that.
And now I just love data science because it's just fun to discover something
cool with data.
One is not preferred. I open the bag
done with that. Did you want, do you ever cook me? Yeah. Uh,
slash can I take some of these ingredients? What was black garlic
Corazon?
Do you remember when I came and make her made Curry with you? Made Curry.
Okay.
I want to say, I'm going to find these questions. Okay. Mitchell Wakefield,
in your opinion,
what are some of the best soft skills to have at a large tech company? And why.
Is a good question? Um,
I would say probably relationship building is a good,
soft skill to have at a tech company or a very large tech company,
because there's a lot of people at a large tech company.
And the way that you're going to work well with other people is to have like
relationships with those people doesn't necessarily have to be like personal
relationships,
but just like having some sort of rapport with a lot of different kinds of
people are going to help you get your job done is also going to help you biting
your, and everyone's going to like, know who you are and stuff.
And sometimes networking is key, especially at larger tech companies recently,
where am I? All right. I can do this. Oh yeah.
What do I do then? I just, all right. Do you know what you're doing? Yep.
Recently, something I've been thinking about is that when you're an engineer,
you can obviously show competence just by writing really good code,
but you can demonstrate so much value by actually taking charge in a project.
And that requires a lot of soft skills.
So like basically like leadership skills, right? Running a meeting,
starting meetings,
being able to talk to all the cross-functional people to get their suggestions
and then like connecting those suggestions to other people.
It just makes you look so much more competent.
And then people will actually start to think of you as someone who can like own
a project and totally bring it through.
And all of that is like soft skills.
All of that's talking to other people talking to other engineers,
maybe like delegating work. Even. I don't have to do that a lot.
So it was really on my mind. You got to, Oh no, it's downloaded.
I thought it was the smell.
It's hot. That's hot. Okay.
Make sure I get a lot of screen time a minute. It's still my channel, right?
Wow. Was your friend married? No,
he's single live there. Yeah. Temporary.
Yeah. Everything. Yeah. I'm sorry. My hands are so,
Oh God,
I don't like guns. Look, are you recording?
Yeah. I don't do things when you're not recording.
Please record him all the time much.
Oh my God. I thought you were going to just,
you want me to eat this? This, this challenge is the challenge.
You don't want the Jason
I'll do [inaudible] what did you learn on the job and not in school that you
wish you learned in school or knew about it earlier? It could be technical.
Could be, yeah. Okay.
So on the job as pushing, you're working at a larger company,
a lot of your work is going to involve going through other people's code.
And that means some things are going to take a variable amount of time and you
just don't know how long you're going to take.
So like scoping a project at school and at work is so different.
At least it was for me, like at school you could play,
do everything the last day, if you really needed to. I mean,
maybe for bigger projects, but at work,
things are just not going to take the amount of time that you think.
So that's something I've really had to learn. And when I was an intern,
I was like, the first time I got, I had to learn that. Yeah.
I wish I improved my writing skills. Yeah.
Cause like I thought I was like, when I was going to school, I was like,
I don't need to write, like, I'm a computer science major.
I don't got to like write anything, like paragraph structure, whatever.
But then I found that like,
whenever you're communicating what you wrote to like what code you wrote or
like, if you're communicating to other people, um, async what you're doing.
Then you have to have really good writing skills to come off clearly and like
communicate really well. So like even just like PRS, right.
When you have to write a really good description of what you just made so that
it makes sense to another person.
And I wish I had like worked on their writing skills. Yeah.
And that is also like one of the soft skills.
And the other question that's true. Yeah. Really important. Soft skill.
Also one more thing is this, it doesn't actually apply to me,
but recently one of our coworkers said that at school things
didn't really check his code. They just checked to see if it worked.
And so that's a thing like your job, if people are going to look at your code,
it can't just work. It has to be like good code. Oh yeah. Quality.
Yeah. I want to talk about this too.
Like coding is not just about how fast your code runs or if it works because the
whole, because coding 90% of the time means you're working with other people.
Yeah. Good code means other people can read your code and then write whole
trash. Like my videos, like my coding skills.
Yeah.
Which programming language is a good prerequisite for computer science,
students and freshmen.
Yeah. For what? Which programming language. Yeah.
Python is good for interviews Python. Yeah. I mean,
it depends what you're doing.
Question by EKI what benefits, if there are any,
do you see in getting a software engineering degree versus a computer science
degree? Yeah.
And how highly do you think companies value self projects versus actual
internship and work experience? So two, two questions. Okay.
Okay. I would say software and you're doing versus computer science.
I'd my school didn't have a software engineering degree,
but I think it depends maybe on like what the school program is and if it aligns
with their goals.
Cause I can imagine like some software engineering programs or just like CS
programs at other schools. So I would say like, if you are at a college,
then talk to your advisor and see which one is like more like what you want to
do. And then the second question, uh,
self projects versus actual internship or work experience,
I guess it depends on what the self project is. But if, unless it,
unless it's like really cool, I would say that like work experience,
actual initiatives, consult projects.
Cause there's a lot of stuff that you learn in internships that aren't just
about coding and it's about like working with a team or working with other
people and communicating and stuff that are really valuable.
I think to learn just my two. How do you.
Keep being productive in software engineering?
More specifically how you do it with hella distraction around you
basically. How do you not procrastinate?
Just always progress. Yeah. Stop.
But I think the accountability systems are good.
Yeah.
I personally do get distracted a lot in general at work
also, but I, I,
I have just learned to accept it because in a day I have a certain amount of
energy. And even if I have more time, like, like eight hours in a day,
it doesn't mean that I'm going to work the whole eight hours.
Cause I just get mentally tired. Right.
So it's okay to procrastinate from time to time. Like for example, studying,
how, how did you not procrastinate?
I had to remove myself from social situations sometimes like go to a
library, like lock myself in a room, you know,
that's kinda how I had to do it.
Also have a nice drink or something like a treat, not like nothing
[inaudible] library. I meant coffee, tea. There's like a Boba place. Yeah.
I guess I would just like get Boba and I'll be like,
this is my treat while I study. And then it kind of puts,
sometimes it puts into that mode,
especially if it's something that you always have when you're studying. Yeah.
That's true. I always have firsthand Coldwell college, so yeah,
not great advice, but just do it. I think at least at work,
other people also want to get stuff done.
Usually at some point that's more like social pressure at work. Cause it's like,
you don't get it done then someone else's. Yeah. That's true.
That's more motivation for people. I don't want to live.
Whereas in college it's like the only person I'm laying down as myself
person, everything looked good. I love you.
Wait, one last question for you guys, which is a simple answer. I think, do you,
as seasoned developer have to refer to documentation and code snippets when
coding at work or do you already have all the knowledge needed in your head?
I'm a robot sits up program. I always look so fun. Oh yeah.
There's so much stuff you can't a hundred percent Mr. Robot.
I Google how to write loops in Python.
At the daily basis. I do use Google a lot. Yeah.
Yeah, yeah. Literally everything I do.
I copy code snip is almost of course having a good coach and the good.
Well, that's the thing that you learned in this season developer.
You just know what's good and bad codes. Perfect. Yeah.
Okay, cool. So here's the food looks very, very delicious.
Thank you my Hugo, thank you Arielle for,
for helping me cook this meal or should we say thank you for cooking.
For me and.
Allow me to help, but yeah, I'm pretty sure this is, um,
surely healthy. I mean, if we look at the nutritional facts,
let's see if it's a Cine, you know, you get 710 calories for this one.
And then for the other ones, six fleets,
we get 610 calories. Yeah. Lots of protein. Both of them. 41 grams,
39 grams.
Let's try it out guys. Try to pass the first fry. Actually.
I'm gonna try out pasta scuffed fish, and I'm going to find
out I only so good.
Well good drama, Yukon. This is.
Let me try. Yo. That's good.
I don't. You mean thank you,
blue aprons for making the recipe and follow
it's good. That was really good. I've never had fish pasta. Yeah.
I don't think I've actually ever made fish pasta before either, but easy.
So good. Yeah. This is actually really good. Really healthy. Oh my God.
I want to try this one. If I could make.
This myself, I'll be, Oh my God. It's over.
Okay. Out the garlic butter, extra butter.
Um, yeah, you get more than just this by the way, eat off of this plate.
Sure. It's just like, why would get in large companies?
Cafeteria food wins are good.
Oh, you don't think so. I think this was definitely better than that or better.
Yeah. I think was better.
It feels like I shopped at whole foods without needing to go to whole foods and
pay for it. Yeah. Yeah. Pretty much.
I think I can do this with my girlfriend.
Come on. Can you just act it just fine?
I could do this connect. My non-existent when your future girlfriend. Yeah,
my future. Hopefully one day I won't get a girlfriend.
Right. So last words.
Thank you so much. Blue apron for sponsoring this video. Oh my God.
We have so much fun making this. Oh my God. So yeah. And once again,
don't forget link on the description to get free. What $50 off.
For your next purchase? All right. Peace out guys.
And then the rap music starts. Oh yeah.
Why always me?
Why always me.